hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
today is all about barbin Heimer that's
right we're looking at Barbie and we're
looking at Oppenheimer two movies that
apparently had zero visual effects
that's just simply not true there are
tons of visual effects in both of these
movies we're going to break down some of
the visual effects and practical effects
from each of these films and it's going
to get a little spicy Sam hasn't seen
the nuke
yet oh wow so they just hit you with the
nuke right away kind of these are more
abstract representations of the quantum
physics going on inside of a nuclear
explosion from a visual standpoint these
abstract images were my favorite part of
the movie they're very pretty but
there's a part of me that like equates
it to like people who are really really
good at Food photography there's people
out there who like make the most amazing
shots of like things flying through the
air and the camera is doing stuff you
never expect it's lit in ways that you
never expect or like the guy who does
the macro stuff on YouTube and that's
stff super cool but I feel like some
shots were more successful than others
when it's just back lit pieces of flower
flying in the air like that's a little
underwhelming other times it's super
cool like the surface of the sun/
nuclear blast there is pretty cool
looking the one with the zooming
particles that one's good that one's my
favorite one I think cuz like my only
critique so far of them is that they
kind of feel a little flat it feels like
a 2d plane look I I feel like you're
looking into a jar right now you know
I'm not like in the jar right but that
paint one is like flying through it or
it's like coming to us has a lot of
Dimension and I'm like I don't know how
you how you film that Pro blend Pro
blend there's actually a YouTube channel
that tried to recreate all these effects
practically oh I saw that CGI that was
good yeah I feel like they did a really
solid job actually water and pigment
powder it shows you that some of the
stuff that Chris Nolan's team is doing
is super inventive and some of the other
stuff is just really accessible the
materials aren't expensive it's not like
you have to build a giant 100 foot Tower
in order to do that it's just dust some
flowers some Fiber Optic Cables and a
thing that spins it really like anyone
can do that you just got to know
how were are you happy with yesterday's
lunch
happy no it was cold underseasoned and
lacking the heart an award-winning Chef
would bring to the
dish but then I discovered today's
sponsor cook Unity cook Unity is the
first chef to Consumer platform
delivering freshly prepared pre-selected
meals right to your door on a weekly
basis it's the most convenient way to
get a wide variety of restaurant quality
food from award-winning chest delivered
right to your door a subscription plan
and select from hundreds of meals each
week flexible subscriptions you can
choose from 4 to 16 meals a week
commitment free skip deliveries pause or
cancel anytime enjoy restaurant quality
meals for a fraction of the price start
as low as $11 a meal today spicy bua
tacos by actar NOAB from Brooklyn New
York these meals are extremely easy to
repair so you can get back to the rest
of your to-do list mine will be ready in
3 2
1 we knew that lunch would not be the
same a few people laughed a few people
cried most people were silent I
remembered the discount code Corridor
crew 50 by clicking the link in the
description below or going to cook
unity.com crew you get 50% off your
first
order delicious now back to react hey
Sam y you want to see a nuclear bomb
absolutely I haven't seen the actual
nuke and apparently it's pretty great
and everyone loved it so I saw this
movie in IMAX theater and I've only seen
this movie Once
I'm about to see the nuke for the second
time ever 3 2
1 this whole scene plays out in complete
silence this is janky as sorry this
is so
janky be nicer Sam be nicer I can't use
footage or you being mean okay this
is Sam is on is a salty rip today so
it's just it just it doesn't look like a
nuke going off that's the thing it looks
like a sweet 80s action explosion just a
nice big old gas explosion remember that
tanker that blew up in whatever that
movie was called Blown Away Blown
Away amazing in almost every other
context I would say this is amazing and
we need more of this in movies but I'm
just saying like right now I'm just
that's what I'm seeing I'm seeing a
non-destructive non-concussive Hollywood
gasoline Fireball I'm like a second out
from the moment when all that gasoline
vapor is done igniting like you can see
it lose moment I see it lose momentum
and then same thing with this next shot
you see it start to fall down that's as
big as it gets I get that he didn't want
to have a giant CG nuclear explosion in
this 100% toally get that you can't go
the exact opposite direction where it
just looks like a 30 foot gas explosion
and expect us to buy that it's a nuke
you see all those little like hot little
sparks flying around there are no sparks
like that in an actual nuclear Fireball
cuz what are those Sparks they're
material that have been ignited or being
flung outwards at super high speed and
are burning as they go
outwards don't really do that the lines
you see from that are the like wires
from the Tower actually like igniting
and ionizing the air the problem is
scale it's all scale at the end of the
day what makes a nuclear explosion so
iconically like destructive is that it's
a huge scale explosion you have all the
different tiny ripples in the edges of
it that appear tiny because the fireball
itself is so huge so if you try to just
do a small EXP expion it just doesn't
look like a nuke because it doesn't have
the correct scaling properties you're
100% right Sam I want to I want to he
you with a little science lesson real
quick there's a thing called a
deflagration and there's a thing called
a detonation and explosions you see in
Hollywood movies are deflagrations when
that fireball is going up it's just
burning fuel but a detonation is
something that expands so fast it
expands faster than the speed of sound
creating a Sonic shock wave what we need
to see from a nuke is a detonation I
think they just needed to grab some
freaking TNT or something which you can
get that's what I was really hoping I
was hoping detonation slow-mo guys they
get debt cord for days people are
blowing up actual Bombs all the time and
I'm just like why couldn't they get
those guys for this can't Chris Nolan
get like one Moab or something you know
like how big of a bomb can you blow up I
did my best to figure this out without
getting put on too many lists and so I
have a clip here of a guy doing I think
it's 100 tons of TNT
well sick so this is what it could
possibly have looked like or at least a
tool they could have possibly have used
they don't necessar go off at the same
time so you're not getting the same
exact you know single blast but the big
thing I notice is there's atmosphere
there's atmospheric effects like there
feels like there's a shock wave like an
actual shock wave coming off this thing
well there is well there is you're right
it's it's a detonative blast if you
would have filmed that with slow motion
cameras that violence of that the last
would be unlike any Hollywood film like
this feels like a military explosion
just like watching the ground that like
that effect of the shock wave and the
dust Rippling across the ground that the
the pressure wave you feel it it makes
it feel concussive when it hits the
camera the that little Rumble you know
that's what you crave when you think
nuke they did that in the movie with air
canons basically I know and it's so
janky and silly looking in that one shot
where they do it it looks like it's just
like this is a 1 kiloton TNT explosion
oh yeah okay so when we're talking
bayroot this is about the same about the
same holy
cow D okay yeah that feels big that feel
like a nuke that feels nuke like to me
it's even got the see that was the other
thing about the nuke in the movie is
that there was never any mushroom cloud
granted the mushroom cloud was dark
smoke against a dark black background so
it' be hard to see but like you could
see the beginnings of a mushroom cloud
with how the fire is curling in on
itself and I never really felt like I
saw any of that that and I saw that here
with this explosion like right away the
crazy thing about a nuke is that that
fireball doesn't go out right away that
fireball is what's Rising you also don't
get that with a gas Fireball just this
glowing ball that just keeps rising and
evolving like it's still burning here in
this shot to do this would have crossed
Christopher Nolan millions of dollars so
I can see why they didn't do it this big
that's such a VFX shot by the way I
always assumed it was a comp shot it
looks like a comp shot it's just like
the strange color temperature mismatch
yeah they're getting hit with the blue
daylight and there's a red Fireball
behind them your light source is not
coming from the explosion also it it
almost looks like the foreground footage
is more Overexposed than the explosion
itself we shouldn't be able to see the
fireball at all right now they have the
color correct the explosion to be
blue and then and add one optical flares
element on it Chris Nolan said he was
avoiding CGI because he didn't want to
distract from the time period of the
movie and I totally get that you start
getting some obvious CGI in this film
and it starts turning into Captain
America to fully commit to be like I'm
not going to have any CGI that triggers
you going oh this is marveles is very
respectable but I think there's ways to
do visual effects to not trigger that
thing in your mind that makes you feel
like now I'm watching animation so you
guys want to look at Barbie yeah yeah
let's do it little change of
pace I don't think of Barbie as a VFX
movie which was very intentional on the
filmmakers part Greta Gerwig had this
phrase that she really loved called
authentic artificiality cuz they wanted
maintain that sort of like tangible
plastic feel of everything despite there
being 1,300 visual effect shots in the
movie it feels like a Wes Anderson film
all real but at the same time it's all
very clearly like art Direction and prop
Department yeah and it really leans into
the idea of using your imagination with
dolls like that's what this movie is
literally about they put a lot of work
into creating all the assets in Barbie
land the foreground elements are real so
she's actually standing on a real
platform that's like 30 feet up in the
air the house immediately to the left
and right are also real sets with real
people on her she's actually got a
harness preventing her from falling
forward off of the building which was
then painted out all of the different
buildings and houses and props they
wanted to make as much as they could for
real as a miniature so they actually
like made all these different things
they even used real Barbie Parts on some
of these things but you don't see any of
that in the final film it's all CG at
the end of the day classic isn't that
always what
happens but they they leaned into it for
this it's the the authentic
artificiality that Greta grunberg was
talking
about God dang it did I
say wait who's grunberg I'm Greg
grunberg she's the
environmentalist yeah I'm pretty sure
she hated this movie what a waste of
plastic Greta gerwick I'm so sorry
people think that it was a waste of time
to make all of these practical
Miniatures to then just not actually use
any of them on the movie and it's like
no that informed so much about what the
style of this movie was going to be and
what everything should look like and it
gives visual effects artists a reference
to actually make something that works
for this so now you have a shot like
this which is 100% CG and it looks
exactly like the previous shot because
everyone's on the same page about what
it should look like and how they should
achieve it it looks like a model somehow
they really nailed the the model Vibe
yeah they kind of look like dolls at
first the animation they do look like
dolls it's crazy they nailed The Lego
Movie School of making your CGI look
like a practical miniature they're fully
animated though it's super weird in a
really great way Sam's liking Barbies oh
Barbies are for
girls so then I find it slightly ironic
that the transition to the real world
didn't have that much CG they actually
made these like fullscale diaramas which
is actually pretty cool like all that
water in the foreground or these
cylinders that are rotating those little
flowers there are actually on a conveyor
belt that's going around like this I
wonder if that little raccoon that
peaked his head out of the hammock was
actually there if that was just like a
little added digital thing yeah it's
digital even the hammock shaking is is
digital so this I think of all the
diaramas probably had the most visual
effects because there's a whole robot
arm that's actually holding that rocket
up that she's sitting on and of course
he's dangling from wires which were
painted out then here is really
interesting cuz now it
transitions to Santa Monica Venice Beach
that's a good transition right it was
actually pretty sweet the ski hill is
tracked in there yeah it's tracked in
there for sure fact they had something
for real there though blocking the light
the Shadows are real the most
unrealistic thing about the scene is
thinking anyone would actually stop and
notice and make fun of people for
dressing like this on Venice Beach
that's actually very
true get in there's a car chase in this
movie that I found really
interesting oh CG car yep you saw it
immediately it's pretty well done like I
can't make a car look that good why do I
immediately see that car as being CG so
the very first thing was the animation
at the top the way it slid felt cartoony
not super cartoony but just a little bit
and I think the other thing is I think
the blue of the car is just maybe a
little too saturated the saturation is
the kind of saturation you get from a
perfect render as opposed to a digital
camera that maybe just doesn't quite
have the best blue sensors it could
possibly have you know dark parts of
that blue car would be less and less
saturated as it gets darker same with
the highlights as it gets brighter that
bright building in the background is
actually kind of pastel colored whereas
a car is not really becoming pastel blue
as it gets brighter and granted it's
been color graded afterwards but that
bump just pushes that CGI feeling
further I mean if you got the blue car
at that high enough Fidelity it's easy
enough to do these black cars as well
right but I was looking at the
reflections on them I'm like I think
those black cars were real the entire
time they do look pretty real yeah I
think you're right if you look on the
road you can see the tire tracks from
the previous take they did it you can
see the skidm mark from when they did
yeah the take before that's funny yeah
they filmed with three cars it's clearly
product placement which is why it's CGI
they probably filmed with like a standin
or a prototype vehicle and then replaced
it with like the final look of this car
later to make that Chevy
money the Chevy the Chevy money the
reflections are flawless in fact you can
see the blue cars reflection in the side
of the SUV yeah there it is you see
it so 2001 Space Odyssey famously had
this whole intro that was filmed using
rear projection and they replicated that
here but instead of using rear
projection they were using these led
stages they put a lot of work into
specifically making these backgrounds
the director was like if Stanley Kubrick
was here today he would probably be
trying to use the most modern tech to do
this there's a CG doll that they're
touching which I thought was pretty
interesting they scanned it from an act
the original first doll that's the very
first Barbie apparently and she's filmed
on a separate plate here she's filmed on
a blue screen but the challenge that I
found to be really interesting was not
one I would have expected but makes so
much sense in hindsight as they're
destroying all of these dolls here
they're shooting it in slow motion which
created an issue with the LED screen
refresh rate they refresh it like 60
times second maybe 120 if you're lucky
but if you're shooting something at 120
or 240 frames per second you have issues
so they had to go through and
essentially do a bunch of Def flicker on
the background or replace the background
entirely my biggest take away from
researching the visual effects in this
movie is that like LED screens just
aren't there yet despite them being used
in a lot of movies and whatnot these
days and people being really excited
about it then it gets replaced at the
end of the day but I don't yet feel that
that's a bad thing definitely
misconception people have where it's
like oh they replace it what a waste of
time it's like well no is you're going
to have to film reference it's best to
just film the reference on the set I I
really want to make this video essay
about informed intent it's the termine
I've been using for years now about like
why there's value in something even if
it's going to be replaced 100% less
Gandalf tears there's less Gandalf tears
few fewer Gandalf tiar you are
pretending and that is acting leave a
comment down below if you got any other
sort of like World War II toy movie
combinations we're we need more of that
or just I need good like girl movies
versus boy movies you know
that's basically what this is
right very often he's too hot for
YouTube so we got to put that spice on
cord digital.com with our extended cuts
of visual effects artist react so yeah
if you want to support us you enjoy the
stuff that we make that's the best place
to do it Cordo digital.com thanks